as a small aside
is there something you could say about
fdr
and hitler
i constantly tried to think can can this
person can this moment in history have
been
um circumvented prevented
can hitler have been stopped can some of
the atrocities from my own family
that like my grandparents had to live
through the
the starvation in the soviet union so
the thing that people don't often talk
about is the atrocities committed by
stalin and his own people
it feels like here's this great leader
fdr that had the chance
to um to have an impact on the world
that um he already probably had a great
positive impact but had uh
had a chance to stop maybe world war ii
or st stop some of the evils
when you look at what how weak hitler
was from much of the 30s
relative to militarily relative to
everything else
how many people could have done a lot to
stop him
and fdr in particular didn't
he tried to play
not pacify but basically do diplomacy
and
let let germany do germany let europe do
europe
and focus on america is there is there
something you would uh would you hold
his feet to the fire on this
or is it very difficult from the
perspective of fdr to have known
what was coming i think fdr had a sense
of what was coming not
quite the enormity of what hitler was
doing and not quite the enormity of what
the holocaust became i also lost
relatives in the holocaust um
and part of that was beyond the
imagination of human beings yes but it's
clear in his papers
um that as early as 1934 people he
respected who he knew well told him that
hitler was
very dangerous they also thought it was
crazy that he was a lunatic hamilton
fish armstrong who is a friend of
of roosevelt uh who was actually the
council on foreign relations in new york
had a meeting with hitler in 1934 i
remember reading the account of this
uh and he basically said definitely this
man is going to cause a war he's going
to cause a lot of damage again they
didn't know quite the scale
so they saw this coming they saw this
coming fdr had two problems
first he had an american public that was
deeply isolationist
the opposite of the problem in a sense
that we were talking about before if
we're an over militarized society
now we were a deeply isolationist
society uh in the 1930s the the
depression reinforced that
fdr actually had to break the law in the
late 30s to support the allies
so it was very hard to move the country
in that direction especially when he had
this program at home
the new deal that he didn't want to
jeopardize by alienating an isolationist
public that was the reality we talked
about political manipulation he had to
be
conscious of that he had to know his
audience and second
there were no allies willing to invest
in this either
the british were as uh as committed to
appeasement as you know you're obviously
very knowledgeable about this the the
french were as well
it was very hard the russian government
the soviet government was cooperating to
re-militarize
germany so there weren't a lot of allies
out there either
um i think if there's a criticism to be
made of fdr
it's that once we're in the war
he didn't do enough to stop in
particular the killing of jews
and there are a number of historians
myself included who have written about
this and it's an endless debate what
should he have done
there's no doubt by 1944 the united
states had
air superiority and could have bombed
the rail lines to auschwitz
and other camps that would have saved as
many as a million jews that's a lot of
people
who could have been saved why didn't fdr
insist on that
um in part because he wanted to use
every resource possible to win the war
he did not want to be accused of
fighting the war for jews but i think
it's also fair to say that he probably
cared less about jews
and east europeans than he did about
others
those of his own dutch ancestry and and
from western europe and so
you know even there race comes in is
also the explanation for the internment
of japanese in the united states which
is a horrible war crime committed by
this heroic president
120 000 japanese-american citizens lost
their freedom
unnecessarily so he had his limitations
and
and i think he could have done more
during the war
to save many more lives and i wish he
had and there's something
to be said about empathy that you spoke
that fdr had
empathy but us for example now there's
many people who describe the atrocities
happening in china
and there's a bunch of places across the
world where there's atrocities happening
now and
we care
we do not uniformly apply how much we
care for the suffering of others
that's correct depending on the group
that's correct and in some sense
the role of the president is to uh
to rise above that natural human
inclination to protect
to do the us versus them to protect
protect the inner circle
and empathize with the suffering of
those that are not like you
that's correct i agree with that yeah
you